à 18 heures le premier ministre jean
castex a une nouvelle fois pris la
parole en direct à la télévision pour
faire un point sur la situation
sanitaire lié à la copie de 19
il est clair que nous ne sommes pas
confrontés à une hausse exponentielle de
l'épidémie lors de ces annonces il a
indiqué un confinement de la région pas
de calais qui vient donc s'ajouter à
celui de dunkerque ivo alpes-maritimes
si la situation est critique en région
parisienne est qu un confinement le
week-end a été envisagée sous la
pression de plusieurs élus cette option
a été écartée
un couvre-feu à 18h reste tout de même
en vigueur dans toute la france si
nombreux sont ceux qui font savoir que
les chiffres de propagation du virus et
de personnes admises en réanimation en
france ne sont pas bons certains
soignants n'hésite pourtant pas à
appeler au retour à la vie normale
c'est le cas par exemple de patrick
lafforgue chef de service en réanimation
de la clinique d'occitanie à muret je
suis pour laisser vivre les gens qui ne
sont pas à risque alors jusqu'ici la
france at-elle pris les bonnes décisions
[Musique]
fabre et l'illusion est encore avec nous
ce soir magnifique fabrice trop ça va
j'écoute un peu booba quoi donc ça va
vous le connaissez bon bah c'est fabrice
des vidéos c'est un avocat très sympa
alors fabrice des vidéos la france
at-elle pris les bonnes décisions
concernant le couvre-feu tout à l'heure
il ya eu une annonce du premier ministre
elle a pris les bonnes décisions pas la
france on est toujours confronté au même
problème
ce à quoi bein c'est savoir moi on fait
des trucs mais pourquoi on les fait je
veux dire non mais on va pas en sortir
c'est à dire que l'on fait chier les
français les français on ne sait pas
grave si on les fait chier à condition
qu effectivement ça soit nécessaire pour
la lutte contre l'épidémie et on est
toujours confronté au même problème
c'est que mis à part un ministre qui
s'auto congratule en disant que tous les
scientifiques s'accordent à dire que le
couvre-feu marche alors s'ils marchent
tellement que c'est pour ça qu'on pense
à un confinement
ils marchent tellement que c'est pour ça
qu'on filme mais c'est pas grave et le
problème c'est qu'à un moment donné
qu'est ce qu'on fait jusqu'où va et
combien de temps je pense qu'il faut
vraiment réaliser qu'à un moment donné
on est à bout tous les français sont à
bout ils n'en peuvent plus et que ça
marche pas à mon donner une épidémie il
faut accepter cette part d'imprévu les
pays qui ont confiné compacte ou filet
ont les mêmes courbes dakota du nord
dakota du sud californie floride j'ai
les courbes de dakota les coupes sont
les mêmes
bah j'arrive de miami moi je fasse ça
fait un an que tu pas venu ici il arrive
de miami où tout est ouvert tout est
ouvert tranquille il n'y a pas de
rentrer c'est même pire parce que le
gouverneur de floride tout au départ
avait effectivement décrété un
confinement en mars avril
le problème c'est qu'il n'a pas été
respecté du tout parce que la floride
que je connais bien d'ailleurs on peut
essayer la floride ouais je connais
floride effectué manger un cabinet aux
états unis donc ça va on dit j'ai des
cabinets ça me permet de parler de
choses que je connais bah oui ma voiture
et que du coup on s'aperçoit de quoi que
la californie qui est la gauche qui l'a
confiné deux ou trois fois la clé mais
la misère ils ont battu la misère ils
ont vécu razr ils ont les mêmes courbes
dakota du nord a confiné pas le dakota
du sud et on a les mêmes courbes mais
regardez on voit bien que c'est le
premier chan et que ce n'est pas une
catastrophe on pense que ça va ça se
passait bien que pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de raison de confiner donc pas en
fait qu'est-ce qu'ils croisent
catastrophe maintenant on a les chiffres
quand même un plat chaud ça veut dire
plateau nommé non mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est ça commence quand la
catalogne james quand tu y as géraldine
non moi je voudrais vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec fabrice di vizio
non moi je trouve qu'effectivement on
appris on a fait plein d'erreurs ça
c'est sûr il ya eu plein de plein de
cagades là après la situation est un peu
exceptionnel
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est dans
votre team c'est à dire qu'il avait
lui-même prend le lead qu'il a voulu
dire écoutez les sanitaires on vous a
beaucoup écouté globalement quoi qu'on
ait fait massa jamais vraiment fait ce
que vous avez voilà il s'est jamais
passé vraiment ce que vous avez dit
qu'il se passerait donc maintenant on va
reprendre une vie à peu près normale et
petit à petit on va desserrer l'étau et
le seul truc en fait c'est de vacciner
parce qu'en fait vous avez raison en
allemagne ils ont confiné strictement
tous les ans tous fermés et ce en train
de repartir avec dia pas dragon c'est
pas le coup le couvre-feu dans et le
confinement le week end on n'a pas de
recul sur dunkerque et sur nice dont
finalement bon on va pas le faire en
fait on sait pas en fait le col il est
toujours devant nous et a toujours deux
coups d'avancé sur nous vous savez où
est ce que vous savez comment l'agro
d'agrial de 1957 la grippe pandémique 57
qui était donc
la grippe asiatique s'est terminée non
comment est bon c'est pas non j'ai ma
famille les épidémies naissent et
meurent avec une part d'inconnu et c'est
celle là qu'il faut accepter et le grip
et d'enfants pensez donc vous pensez
vous fabrice que ça va disparaître et
qu'il n'agira pas mettez non vous savez
bien ici que moi j'avais pas là pour je
sais je sais je sais c'est pas ça le jeu
dit qu'en fait à partir du moment on est
en train de créer des dégâts recensés au
restaurant avec moi si un concert j'ai
envie d'aller en boîte de nathan peu
plus là bas moi j'habite à miami ça fait
un an que tu au miami à miami tout est
ouvert mais quand arrive quand tu mets
ici six quoi c'est la 2 c'est la torpeur
n'a aucun sens mais à miami a pas mal
souffert d'aucun sens il avait de la vie
n'ont pas de moi fabrice vidéo vous avez
eu booba est d'accord avec vous mais
c'est bien à défoncer le bas il est vrai
énervé devant booba est ce que tu as
juste d'eric juste dire que toi tu es
pour le confinement
il a la qualité de l'honnêteté beaucoup
dans maple marie va voir régime
moi je pense qu'on vit un peu ouais ça
j'arrive ici ça ressemble un peu à une
dictature parce qu'on nous demande même
pas notre avis c'est même pas 2 je sais
pas comment on appelle ça les gens on
n'aime pas j'ai des gens m'aiment pas
leur mot à dire et mais on allume la
télé nous diront si jérôme chez toi
confie n'est pas confiné qu'elles n'ont
vraiment plus il
des lois dans des assemblées vide à quel
moment quoi bon choix c'est une
démocratie
ces intersections ne vois pas ce qu'on
vous dit rien vous dit les choses
aillent en sont d'accord pour sa
d'accord pour moi je jeudi le batave
mais c'est en démocratie majorité
non mais ça va même faire s'il n'y a pas
de vote il faut avoir conscience
aujourd'hui comme booba bizarrement il
alors on voulait énormément n'existe
plus aujourd'hui
ça existe plus parlement un accord
t'adore la démocratie n'y a plus de
démocratie c'est le gouvernement qui
décide victor s'est on n'est pas loin de
quelque chose qui est en train d'y
ressembler quand même là on est en train
de se poser des questions sur le plan
des libertés publiques c'est que ça va
mal finir ces histoires si oui ça ne
peut que mal finir mon inquiétude est
dès lors en tant qu'avocat en tant que
juriste
j'ai quand même 20 ans d'expérience à
ces questions j'ai bon voilà un cabinet
à mon avis oui j'ai dans pamiers à
washington
mais le mais c'est vachement plus
glamour miami que washington
le truc c'est que on s'aperçoit d'une
chose en fait si le peloton commence à
toucher aux libertés un gouvernement qui
nous empreinte de liberté ne voulait
rend jamais jamais seul quand on est
malade on s'en fout ce soir et nuit vous
avez aimé l'argent mais on voulait
semaine mais la sq mais alors là aussi
si vous voulez pas de réponse mauvaise
réponse parce que c'est caricatural mais
c'est caricatural des états unis c'est
un mauvais exemple en matière de santé
c'est vrai à certains égards je peux
vous dire que ça maintenant très très
cher c'est un système compliqué d'abord
et on se dire qu'en france on peut se
faire soigner et ben alors quand vous
regarder dans le détail on peut se faire
soigner mais finalement 1 à quel prix au
sens où effectivement des soins de
qualité
ne vous trompez pas ça coûte cher des
soins de qualité même en france et
qu'aujourd'hui si vous voulez réellement
des soins de qualité et est repérée ou
quoi que ce soit dans des délais
raisonnables
c'est pas
robinet dans un ace parallèle on a été
déclassé alors merci alors merci c'est
moi